ainsi en tentant la fortune les français
soulage l'importunent créé en 1933 par
l'état la loterie nationale est alors
destiné aux anciens combattants de la
grande guerre
d'abord mensuel l'ancêtre du loto de la
française des jeux devient hebdomadaire
en 1943 des millions de français y
participent et parmi les gagnants
certains désirent garder leur anonymat
et aux fêtes telles sommes d'argent qui
vous est tombé du ciel
et bien pour le moment je les place et
ou du moins en partie
et j'en ai gardé quand même un petit peu
dans le cas où j'aurais une affaire
intéressante à faire grâce à son prix
abordable
la loterie nationale est un succès mais
dans les années 70 le tiercé gagnant du
terrain
les sociétés de courses privé empiète
alors sur le monopole des jeux d'argent
de l'état en dehors du tiercé ce que
vous jouez un autre jeune aujourd'hui
quand t'es jamais votre chance ailleurs
mais l'écart verriers du tout je ressors
la loterie nationale
la loterie nationale ne fait plus
l'unanimité pour y remédier l'état va
donc lancer un nouveau jeu d'argent 1976
le fameux loto il présente alors deux
différences avec sa grande soeur
le montant du jackpot non plafonné et
surtout la possibilité de choisir ses
numéros
le principe est très amusant et s'agit
simplement de choisir 6 numéros sur 49
quoi de plus simple et et quoique peu
amusant après des débuts poussifs
le loto devient un phénomène de société
l'état flaire alors le bon coup et fonde
la société de la loterie nationale et du
loto national en 1979 il devient alors
actionnaire majoritaire à 51 %
combien le loto rapporte-t-il à l'état
chaque année
alors le loto et la loterie rapporte
chaque année de l'ordre de 700 à 800
millions en l'état que des choses en
1989 la sln hélène devient transphotos
puis enfin la française des jeux en 1991
la part de l'état dans le capital passe
à 72% au début des années 90 la fdj
lance tic premiers jeux à gratter
elle est ensuite à l'initiative de
laurent mignon une cagnotte européenne
en partenariat avec l'espagne le
royaume-uni en 2004 une révolution
aujourd'hui dans le monde du jeu le
lancement de la nouvelle loterie
européenne baptisée euro millions
aujourd'hui la fdj est privatisée avec
la mise en bourse du groupe
la part de l'état dans son capital est
passé de 72 à 20%
[Musique]